ladies and gentlemen the oscar-nominated
star of volver and the bull bear reading
himself Penelope Cruz and Hugh Jackman
tonight's nominated composers in the
Best Original Score category come to
Hollywood from Argentina France Spain
Los Angeles an exotic and faraway
trailer Baltimore oh this was an
international year tonight one of them
will join the roster of talented
expatriates have received Oscars for
writing the music of the movies
composers like Franz Waxman Demetri
champion Marie char and Charlie Chaplin
or he might be from Baltimore here are
the nominees for Best Original Score
Babel by Gustavo Santaolalla
the good German by Thomas Newman
notes on a scandal by Philip Glass
Pan's Labyrinth by Xavier now already
the queen by Alexandre de plan and the
Oscar goes to
Gustavo Santaolalla
Gustavo Santo Elias said that his hope
for the store of Babel was for it to not
sound like the music of a National
Geographic documentary
thank you so much members of the Academy
in our sole rest
I think our own true identity beyond
languages countries races and religions
I'm so proud to work in Babel a film
that helped us understand better who we
are and why and what are we here for
if you thanks I want to thank John
lesser Brad grey John Killick Steve
Golan our messenger Lynn Feinstein an
evil careful my wife Alejandra my kids
and a loon I don't want my mother the
man my mentor director and friend my
amigo Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu and
last but not least I want to dedicate
this to my dad para o Viejo peril
Argentina and once again para toll on
Latinos gracias thank you
you know I just want to say it can be
kind of intimidating and scary to be up
here and look out at everybody in the
audience and every time I come out here
Jack Nicholson is smiling and laughing
and it's just it made me feel so good
and then a while ago I saw him back
there in the corner by himself smiling
and laughing and shaving and he has a
good time I like it
speaking of a good time the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences is much
more than just the Oscars so we've
challenged President Sid Ganis to tell
us everything about the Academy in under
60 seconds I bet him a dollar he can't
do it but he thinks he can so here he is
the president of the Academy Sid Ganis
we preserve the auto films ranging from
Hollywood classics to documentaries from
animated shorts to the avant-garde how a
film archive contains almost 50,000
different titles we also have the Margot
Herrick library the greatest Research
Centre in the world for motion pictures
with more than 27,000 books 60,000
screenplays 25,000 posters and over
seven million photographs in the past
twelve months we produce gala tributes
to jannecke Dana Olivia de Havilland
Mexican star Lupita Tovar legendary film
editor Dede Allen and director Otto
Preminger but it's not just about the
past we are at the forefront of digital
media through our Science and Technology
Council which helps set the industry
standards for 21st century movie magic
this year we honor 13 great young
filmmakers with Student Academy Awards
we gave cash fellowships the six
brilliant new screenwriters through our
nickel fellowships we helped finance 19
different film festivals margin small
around the country and 60 different
cultural organizations around the world
we exhibited hair allows photographs and
WC Fields archives we had exhibitions
about the Mexican cinema animatronics
and costume design traveling throughout
the world and finally on a seven acre
lot smack in the heart of Hollywood we
have started planning what will be the
most ambitious and remarkable project in
our history a motion picture museum but
my minutes up so we're gonna have to
tell you about it next year
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Sid Ganis